what's up guys
the hobbit the desolation of smaug it's
hitting theaters soon so we decided to
simply take it upon ourselves to decide
what is the ultimate Fantasy franchise
of all time well we're gonna try to
answer that question and we have an
awesome panel to help us out first he is
one of the schmoes from schmoes no Fame
check them out at youtube.com slash
Moe's no and check out Kristian harloff
hello everybody what's going on
she is delightful and vivacious actress
host check her out on Twitter at Alison
Haislip it's Alison hazel it is me hey
surprise guys we got a heavy heavy task
at hand here we have picked four
franchises to be in contention of
ultimate Fantasy franchise Lord of the
Rings slash Hobbit Harry Potter Game of
Thrones and The Chronicles of Narnia now
some people might ask why the hell did
you not put Star Wars in there right our
criteria had to be based on books and
Star Wars is sci-fi no takes place in
the past and different planets doesn't
it's fantasy in space but I'll give you
that it's not based on books fantasy
book Campion spaceships no ships no
spaceships so we're breaking this down
bracket style it's gonna be two on two
and then the winners of each will move
on and we will decide the ultimate Final
Fantasy champion let me remind you guys
this is screen junkies it's not book
junkies ultimately it is about the
filmed adaptations of these books our
first matchup okay Game of Thrones vs.
The Chronicles of Narnia Game of Thrones
destroys Narnia no question about it
there's no comparison you're more
invested in Game of Thrones and you are
on anything in arunya I will argue
though Game of Thrones is really the
only one that's been written for adults
so I do think we're kind of giving
Narnia a bit of a hard rap because we're
putting up against a world that was
truly just created for adults still it's
just the characters and we're talking
fantasy movies that's what you're trying
to hook people in the movies it didn't
do it in Orion if this is not a
franchise that sustaining itself right I
mean they lost me at Prince Caspian
frankly since we are
going with the film data annotations yes
you gotta go Game of Thrones there's no
question great so yeah we're all agreed
Game of Thrones and a walkover yep
nice this next one might not be as easy
Lord of the Rings Hobbit versus Harry
Potter Oh based on the movies - based on
the movies Harry Potter was so fun I
loved the films but I wasn't as attached
to the source material as I was to what
Tolkien stuff means to me
yeah and they're just so massively epic
that I have to go Lord of the Rings
Hobbit even though the first Hobbit film
is weak I'll give you that for me if it
was just Lord of the Rings there's those
three movies against Harry Potter this
would be a lot tougher and I would say
it's probably be Lord of the Rings as
far as right now I'm going Harry Potter
because it's not it's not an easy
decision I love the Lord of the Rings
the first three movies but we're talking
about The Hobbit that just came out I
still don't know what the hell is going
on in that movie it's worth singing and
dancing eating food for 25 minutes yeah
look I am very excited for the second
movie however I haven't seen those two
movies yet I have seen all the Harry
Potter movies those kids were great
actors the filming the music that styled
by that much Harry Potter so we have one
for ranging Hobbit and one for Potter oh
it's a Sophie's Choice you guys and so
Harry Potter just whisks you away to a
world of like whimsy and joy but there's
also like darkness and evil and that's
beautiful that has so many layers Lord
of the Rings
it's almost holy I gotta go Lord of the
Rings are you talking about extended
versions or regular oh god I think that
is it I think that is a good question I
think you have to take everything that
was filmed I think you have to do
extended by no means am i saying oh it's
it's definitely Harry Potter you're
talking about six movies and you have
not both you have not seen those other
two movies yeah you're just basing it
off of everything you've read and
because of you're basing it off the
original trilogy I could look like a
total idiot even more than I do already
um I'm pacing it now here from now right
whatever Christian makes some great
points and this is not a layout this
decision okay so this
is oh my god these two franchises both
incomplete Game of Thrones Lord of the
Rings yeah I mean what are we even
should we just stop now no I think we're
too far into our journeys right now how
oh you know it's interesting because you
know the whole the whole premise of Game
of Thrones is that it's based in this
world where there used to be magic and
then for some reason all the magic kind
of died out and now here they are three
four hundred years later and the magic
starting to seep back into the world and
that's why Dragons have been reborn the
White Walkers and all that kind of stuff
yeah it's almost interesting to think
that Game of Thrones could be taking
place three or four hundred years after
after Lord of the Rings
George Armand ouch you just completed it
and you made our argument yeah I'm gonna
I'm kind of gonna go with my last point
on this um and strangely enough I'm
gonna pick the Lord of the Rings Hobbit
over Game of Thrones and I love Game of
Thrones Lord of the Rings I know how it
all tamale ends I know that even if I
have two missing chapters I know how it
all goes down I don't know the case with
Game of Thrones Game of Thrones
let's hope George our Martin stays
around for a very long time but he's an
older man if he's not around for a while
and somebody else writes some stories we
could get garbage george RR martin
please miss your blog no and start just
like eating some salads working out a
little bit oh my god please take care of
yourself sir
we'd Bank of you you make a lot of great
points and it's true that a Lord of the
Rings it is the granddaddy there would
not be one without the other but
sometimes something comes along that
does it and does it one better
Lord of the Rings and Hobbit are
masterfully filmed what I think
surpasses it in Game of Thrones is the
way it delves into the way people really
operate it has the fantasy and the more
complex humanity I go Game of Thrones
that puts us deadlocked at 1-1 Game of
Thrones look at how loose a hobbit
Alison Haislip all right look I am
obsessed with Game of Thrones
yeah I love love love love love love
love the series like I said before I'm
even okay with the fact that they
changed things in the show that are
different from the books for that very
reason I need to choose Lord of the
Rings Hobbit because I think they stick
so true to the source material that you
cannot fault them for that and I think
when it when a when a filmed adaptation
of a book can be that true to what it
came from you have to give that that
film credit for being as amazing as it
is and there you have it it's more to
the Rings Hobbit the greatest ultimate
Fantasy franchise of all time do you
agree do you disagree as to one we left
out dune Conan the Barbarian the Sex in
the City ladies let us know in the
comments section below best answer I'm
gonna get a screen junkies t-shirt I
want to thank my guest Kristian harloff
subscribed to schmoes know on YouTube
Alison Haislip follow her on Twitter
you'll be in a world of vivacious
delights I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter and thanks for watching
bye bye yeah hunty seen a bunch of good
guys getting together to fight one
villain and this is a bunch of villains
getting together to fight one guy mr.
sinister sick yeah it's really really
cool and like Mike said you know that
the 12 year old me is like we should
just mr. six